we are following breaking news on the
investigations into the Boeing 737 max
jet crashes Indonesian investigators
this morning confirmed that an off-duty
pilot was in the cockpit of the same
lyin airplane that experienced trouble
one day before a deadly crash they did
not say whether he helped stabilize that
plane
the lead investigator says the off-duty
pilot was not in their initial report on
the October crash because investigators
had not spoken to him yet Boeing 737 max
jets are grounded in the US and around
the world following the Indonesia crash
and another about five months later in
Ethiopia 346 people were killed in the
two disasters
Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan National
Airport outside Washington with the
latest Chris good morning well good
morning the FBI is joining a growing
list of agencies demanding answers to
include the Department of Transportation
inspector general members of Congress
and the Defense Department after last
week's crash of Ethiopian Airlines
flight 302 a Boeing employee received a
subpoena to retain records relating to
the approval of the 737 max Department
of Transportation inspector general
agents told employees at the FAA Seattle
office to do the same David Gomez is a
retired FBI executive with experience in
crash investigations what did the FAA
and Boeing know when did they know it
and did they tell anybody about it or
did they hide that the probe is focused
on the process to approve the 737 max is
safe and air worthy a process that by
design allows the manufacturer to
certify much of the plane itself if
there is any kind of documentation that
indicates that they they knew there was
a problem and and either didn't resolve
it to the satisfaction of the FAA or
didn't reveal that that could put them
in jeopardy in terms of a possible
criminal violation boeing is the
nation's largest exporter and one of the
world's biggest defense contractors the
Defense Department's inspector general
has launched an ethics investigation
into acting defense secretary Patrick
Shanahan a former Boeing executive to
see if he inappropriately pushed for
Boeing products Senator Richard
Blumenthal a Shanahan about the inquiry
last week do you support such an
investigation
yes I do Shanahan in a statement said he
is committed to upholding his ethics
agreement with the Department of Defense
Boeing executives are expected to
testify in front of a Senate committee
next week about the 737 max Anthony so
many questions still there about that
plane Chris thank you very much